I have a real gash here - my nose is
broken in two places and the scar here
was that's where the the wife of my
skull was showing bloodied and bandaged
the 46 year old Instagram these intense
pics of his onset injury scared three
weeks ago in Morocco we caught up with
him on the Vancouver set of the Fox
reboot to find out what really happened
I was just running into a prison to get
my brother out and I just felt this
extraordinary explosion on my head that
explosion he felt an overhead iron bar
breaking loose during his prison run
blood was just pouring all over me and
then my stunt guy came up to me and he
said well here's the thing gets cut open
and I can see your skull your nose is
smashed on the other side of my face and
I just sat there really calmly obviously
I was in shock luckily his longtime
girlfriend 90210 star AnnaLynne McCord
was by his side
she went into raging mullen mode and
pulled out whiskey or whatever it was in
my head cuz that's what we had at the
time and wrapped my head in gauze and
yeah it was pretty gnarly
you have to breathe through your mouth
also on hand a top Moroccan plastic
surgeon who quickly repaired Dominic's
injuries and he was back in action a few
days later amazingly with only a few
minor scars and one crazy story to show
for it all when it happened was like wow
one minute you can be here the next you
may not that was just one of those
things where you know I dodged the
bullet